hello everyone
well I still recall the first time I
even heard the concept or the word open
signs right it was a year ago I was a
first year research Master student in
marketing at Silver University and I was
attending this class on data preparation
and workflow management until then I had
worked on small scale projects like my
bachelor thesis where it was just a
small data set and I was the sole author
but now I was going to be dealing with
okay projects that involved large
complex unstructured data collaborating
with team members or co-authors on codes
and this course taught me a new and
efficient way of working on empirical
projects embodying the principles of
open science it was super valuable to me
at that time as a student and a budding
researcher
um just starting off with my career and
I learned how to structure and automate
my workflow how to version my codes with
GitHub and collaborate with others much
more efficiently on large-scale
empirical projects and this course was
made open source available at toolbox
science Hub and that's when I stumbled
upon this initiative and the plethora of
resources available at the site and it
got me excited about value of open
science and I decided to join the
initiative so the organization so hi
again everyone my name is roshni I work
as a research assistant at toolbox
science Hub and I also have travesty
here somewhere in the audience I guess
who is an assistant professor at Silver
University in marketing and she's also
one of the core members in till book
science Hub and we're super excited to
present what this site is all about so
till book science Hub is an open science
initiative which strives to improve
accessibility of state-of-the-art tools
and resources to help facilitate much
better open science alignment in a
One-Stop shop format so now I'm super
excited to take you through our platform
and talk a bit about our contributions
to the open science movement
so
the whole question of like why do we
need open science practices stems from
this conflict between research values
and incentives that we see in Academia
and also in industry in various other
forms so these practices like Open
Access Data sharing pre-registration
really enables much better open science
alignment so of course the benefits of
open science are super clear others can
build on your work your work is super
transparent they can get inspired reuse
your code incorporate the best practices
and as probably an academic you can
answer questions about your work years
after publication and having things Open
Access helps you reach a broader
audience and this applies to people in
industry or like independent
content creators there and also when you
document your workflow you really uh you
know minimize any kind of buggy or
errors that you might make
but practicing open science isn't always
easy because it requires a lot of like
steep learning curves and acquiring new
skill sets and you might be dealing with
co-authors or team members in your
company who have much more traditional
skill sets and it can be a bit harder to
onboard them so how do you still get
people to contribute to open science
projects
and that's where our initiative comes in
it's a field book science Hub is a new
online platform helping researchers
students and data scientists start with
open science one step at a time so our
impacts on students is that like for
example just me I learned open science
skills through the site and teachers can
also use our resources to illustrate
certain things in the classroom or even
publish their materials on a site and
researchers and data scientists can use
the tools and resources available to
onboard your team to use open science
practices
so our site is built on three key
pillars building blocks tutorials and
examples so I'm going to quickly walk
you through what are building blocks
it's basically the DNA of our platform
where it takes the concepts into small
doses and we explain Theory and the
information of Concepts in such a way
that we add real life examples and have
ready to implement code Snippets in
various programming languages or
operating operating systems that's just
easy for you to
um yeah just look at it and then see
okay this is what I need and easily
implement it to your own existing
projects so it's mainly targeted towards
more advanced users who kind of know
what they're looking for and then you
can just uh yeah mix and match uh
whatever contents you need from there
that will be the code or certain tips
and tricks so that's what our building
blocks are all about
tutorials are like a bit of a more like
broader Concepts where we try to tie in
different independent building logs it's
like making Lego bricks right so we
structure them together in a
step-by-step
um tutorial like guide format and it's
much more targeted towards let's say
beginners who want to get a good grasp
over a certain concept for the first
time and have all the right resources in
one page or one tutorial so tutorials
are super handy for beginners who just
want to you know learn for example
um how do I and scrape a dynamic website
or whatever right so we have uh super
useful tutorials out there and the third
pillar that we have are examples so
these are usually real life cases
Publications templates or research
projects that really tying stuff
together so it beat certain building
blocks or tutorials and you really see
how that can be kind of tied to get into
this final product and you can use that
as an example a project or something and
get inspired and try it out on your new
projects as well so we have certain
examples that's super handy so
it's kind of how it looks on our site so
yeah that was pretty much my little tour
into our site thank you so much for
listening you can scan this QR code to
get access to the site right away and
you can also feel free to reach out to
us via Twitter our LinkedIn we're always
looking for more feedback and
suggestions and please join our
community you can make their
contributions to the site by just making
a pull request right so
um yeah thank you so much for listening
and I think yeah if you have I think we
have plenty more time so if you have any
questions about it you can always put
them in the chat and I think uh it'll be
moderated
so yeah thanks for listening and have a
great conference